it's Monday August fifteenth I'm Mary
and you're watching GS news we got
trailers we got delays we got ps4
updates we got it all first up we got
trailers for fallout 4 is dlc nucca
world and battlefield one prepare your
eyes let's start with nucca world the
park has the allure of camp crusty
fantastically written with a theme song
to go along with it you'll be going
through safari adventure dry Rock Gulch
kitty kingdom and the Galactic zone with
games to play and rides to go on and
Raiders to kill this is the sixth and
final expansion for Fallout 4 you can
get all that dlc included in the
fifty-dollar fallout 4 DLC pass
alternatively you can just buy new cold
on its own for twenty bucks this
releases on August 30th for xbox one ps4
and PC but wait there's more battlefield
one released info on their open beta as
well as a trailer highlighting
horse-based ground combat aerial
dogfights and the biggest unstoppable
beast of them all in armored train dice
announced today that battlefield one's
open beta will begin on august 31st
across xbox one ps4 and pc battlefield
insiders get to play it early you have
until august twenty-first to sign up get
going in the battlefield 1 beta the map
supports a wide range of gameplay
including boots on ground skirmishes and
dog fights in the sky this Maps behemoth
vehicle is an armored train you don't
get much more behemoth than getting hit
by a train battlefield one comes out on
October 21st for xbox one ps4 and PC
next up I hate to be the bearer of bad
news so I won't be Hajime Tabata
announced directly to fans that Final
Fantasy 15 is delayed Square Enix has
confirmed a new launch date for the game
Final Fantasy 15 will be released
globally on November 29th this is nearly
two months later than its previously
scheduled September 30th launch date
according to a statement released by
square the new date will allow the
development teams to further polish and
conduct quality testing so that the
reality the game can
the expectations of both fans and
creative teams but then game director
Hajime Tabata made a video apologizing
saying the moment we joined this project
our vision was to create a level of
freedom and realism previously unseen in
the series regrettably we need a little
bit more time to deliver on this vision
and are confident that this new release
date will help us achieve this as the
director and lead of this project I wish
to personally apologize for the
additional weight as a team we want
Final Fantasy 15 to achieve a level of
perfection that our fans deserve we
kindly ask for your understanding
response has been mostly understanding
with people appreciating his candid and
honest response to fans have been
waiting patiently for this game another
two months seems reasonable to make a
project 10 years in the making and make
it the best experience possible we're
waiting finally we have details on the
major ps4 four-point-oh update + bonus
images in a post on the PlayStation Blog
sony's john kohler outlined some of the
new features for the update which
includes a UI refresh more organization
tools in the form of folders updates the
quick menu screen and more people in the
public beta program who are selected for
the beta should now be on the lookout
for an email with details on how to get
started but let's go over those updates
first polar said the ps4 main user
interface is changing to become more
refined and easier to use the overall
look will remain the same but a lot of
adjustments and improvements have been
made that includes some changes you
might notice right away like new system
backgrounds and revised what's new tab
to smaller changes like updated pop-up
notifications and redesigned system
icons there's been changes to the Quick
Menu to make it faster and easier to use
quote-unquote with the update applied
the menu will only cover a portion of
the screen so you don't need to
completely leave gameplay to access it
that's pretty nice some other bonus
things Twitter videos uploaded from ps4
can now be a hundred and forty seconds
long remember when they were only ten
seconds I do wow that's nuts ps4
four-point-oh also adds much requested
folders in the ps4 in an effort to help
users organize their content better also
big changes coming to the
brary there's now a tab called purchased
which shows everything you own across
games apps demos all of it together the
games and application tabs will focus on
the content you have installed instead
of just everything additionally this
update gives you the ability to view
your trophies offline lastly the update
changes the look of the user profile
page this is an attempt to make it
easier to see all the important
information right away the beta is set
to begin in early August you have until
then to sign up to participate get on it
so that's all I have for you today but
I'll see you again tomorrow and the rest
of this week as jess is in Fiji let us
all be jealous of her together I'll see
you guys again tomorrow
you